madame monsieur bonsoir bienvenue dans
ce journal de vente opération
d'envergure ce matin pour évacuer le
squad de l'ancienne cité universitaire
de cachan une intervention qui met fin à
l'occupation illégale de plusieurs
centaines de personnes certaines sans
papiers la préfecture parle de nécessité
sanitaire les associations dénoncent un
coup de force
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire versée
aujourd'hui avec quinze jours d'avancé
268 euros pour aider les familles aux
revenus modestes au liban l'image à
retenir c'est le déploiement depuis ce
matin de l'armée libanaise dans le sud
du pays c'est une première depuis 40 ans
dans le même temps l'elysée annonce
l'envoi immédiat de deux cents hommes
pour remporter la finale
mille milliards de dollars c'est le
montant de la recette générée par les
ventes de pétrole cette année
une flambée ci fait la fortune des pays
producteurs en premier lieu l'arabie
saoudite où l'argent continue de couler
à flots à la fin de ce journal le rêve
fou d'un passionné de vieilles pierres
depuis dix ans il s'est lancé dans la
construction d'un château fort avec les
outils du moyen-âge le décès de bernard
rapp une figure du service public
il s'est éteint à l'âge de 61 ans grand
reporter puis présentateur il avait
orienté sa carrière vers le petit moment
c'est elle le plus grand squat de france
pendant trois ans près d'un millier de
personnes souvent sans papiers occupent
et l'ancienne cité universitaire de
cachan aujourd'hui la préfecture a
décidé d'agir pour des raisons de
sécurité un gros dispositif a été mise
en place pour évacuer les lieux
l'opération a commenté tôt ce matin
karine comazzi tôt maillard 9h ce matin
plus de 500 crs investissent les
couloirs de la cité universitaire de
cachan pour les familles maliennes et
ivoiriennes trois ans de squats prenne
fin un déploiement de force qui devait
se faire à l'abri des caméras et lourdes
les expulser n'évoque aucune violence
dijon prof à la forge quand même
nous on indiqué on peut préparer nos
affaires avant 13 heures le trésor et
l'évacuation commence un long et lent
cortège quitte l'immeuble de cinq étages
500 personnes dont 140 enfants des
femmes et leurs maris beaucoup
s'apprêtaient à partir travailler
parmi eux de nombreux sans-papiers
certaines soixantaine ne passeront pas
le barrage emmené dans cette tente jaune
placé en garde à vue dans des
commissariats ont d'abord une audience
auprès concevoir son parti qui est
partie et vous on les envoie quelques on
va en faire on veut vraiment savoir nous
sommes là on ne sait rien du tout dans
l'incertitude les rumeurs d'expulsion
commencent à circuler
et très vite l'attention les forces de
l'ordre tentent d'expliquer 350 chambres
d'hôtels sont disponibles vous propose
les gens
n'apparaît pas sur ma famille
on n'a pas peur comme cet homme moins de
la moitié des familles ont accepté
l'offre de relogement à l'hôtel pour 10
jours ou un mois
c'est selon qu'on est des papiers ou pas
alors que les premiers bus s'ébranle ce
soir beaucoup refusent toujours de
partir au campement s'organise il
pourrait durer toute la nuit selon la
préfecture ce bâtiment a donc été évacué
pour des raisons sanitaires mais les
associations parlent de coup de force
en tout cas beaucoup de questions se
posent sur l'avenir de ces familles et
sur la date choisie pour évacuer le
squale anouk burel à la location
pourquoi le plus grand squat de france
at il été évacué en urgence le préfet de
région invoque une raison sanitaire des
expertises ont révélé la présence
d'amiante dans le bâtiment des risques
de saturnisme et d' incendies et la
situation se serait dégradée ces
derniers mois il y avait un risque
majeur majeure tant de sécurité incendie
que de sécurité sanitaire les
associations et la gauche quant à elle y
voit surtout une manoeuvre politique
en écho aux récentes déclarations de
nicolas sarkozy ce qu'a prévu le préfet
c'est de profiter de l'été pour essayer
de vider le squat de mettre les gens
soient la rue soit ensemble de rétention
on rassure son électorat en montrant en
montrant des signes de fermeté en
faisant évacuer par la force
c'est ce soit mais pourquoi maintenant
après trois ans de squat depuis avril
2003 près d'un millier de personnes
vivent est ici hors la loi un an après
l'occupation est officiellement illégal
décision du tribunal depuis toutes les
négociations ont échoué
les occupants pour la plupart des sans
papiers ont toujours refusé de partir
sans avoir une garantie de relogement
impossible pour l'administration vu leur
statut c'est une impasse
que vont-ils devenir pour l'instant il
n'y a que des solutions temporaires 350
chambres d'hôtel ont été réquisitionnés
pour un mois au maximum
ils ont annoncé un mois d'hébergement à
l'hôtel
pour certains pour d'autres ces dix
jours pour d'autres il semblerait que ce
soit encore plus court donc notamment
pour les familles sans papiers donc
en attendant d'en savoir un peu plus la
seule certitude concerne le bâtiment
il doit être complètement démolie
avant-hier sur notre antenne nicolas
sarkozy avait confirmé sa décision
d'augmenter les reconduites à la
frontière pour les personnes sans
papiers bien aujourd'hui 73 roumains ont
été ramenés dans leur pays par un vol
groupé affrété à l'aéroport de roissy
devant l'émotion suscitée par la mort
des trois pompiers de puget-ville
jacques chirac a choisi de suspendre ses
vacances pendant quelques heures pour se
rendre dans la commune en deuil et un
geste de solidarité alors que l'on
s'interroge encore sur les circonstances
du drame
linkedin boudaoud michel coma le visage
grave
le chef de l'état et son épouse sont
accueillis par le maire de puget ville
les amis des trois pompiers disparus
leurs familles sont réunis dans la cour
de la caserne dans le malheur les 45
pompiers volontaires du village font
encore jacques chirac s'adresse à eux
loin des objectifs
les familles endeuillées ont ensuite été
réconfortés par le couple présidentiel
l'expression
que j'ai tenus avec mon épouse a formulé
de la solidarité de toutes les
françaises et de tous les français et de
leur compassion à l'égard une fois
encore malheureusement de ce drame et je
tenais simplement mais de tout coeur à
leur rendre l'hommage qui leur est dû le
président de la république s'est incliné
devant les photos et les casques des
pompiers décédés mardi dernier dans un
accident au retour d'une intervention
sur un feu de forêt
la démarche du chef de l'état a touché
les soldats du feu ça donne ça prouve
que on pense on est un allié de la
reconnaissance prolos c'est ça et ça
chauffe le coeur d'une part et ça nous a
encore plus ce pas dire ça nous apaiser
mais ça nous a rassurés
les obsèques des trois pompiers auront
lieu samedi matin les causes de
l'accident ne sont pas établies aucune
trace d'alcoolémie n'a été révélé par
les autopsies des victimes
prenant si vous habitez l'est de la
france un bulletin de vigilance orange a
été émis pour 22 départements de
violents orages sont attendus les
régions concernées vous le voyez se
situe sur un axe étendant de l'est du
languedoc jusque vers le luxembourg
une mini tornade s'est d'ailleurs déjà
abattu sur la commune de châtillon sur
seine en côte-d'or en 30 minutes à peine
elle a endommagé un gymnase et de
nombreuses toitures 800 foyers sont
toujours privés d'électricité avec
quinze jours d'avancé
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire a été
versée aujourd'hui trois millions de
personnes bénéficient de ce coup de
pouce de 268 euros par enfant les
associations de défense des familles
regrette que cette somme ne varie pas en
fonction des âges séverine lebrun air
des poteaux
il y en a des tonnes et encore les
courses de rentrée ne sont pas terminés
sont la famille il y a trois filles
scolarisées chacune touchent
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire 268
euros 1,8 pour cent de plus que l'année
dernière mais pour la maman l'addition
est quand même salle et une rentrée lui
coûte près de 1000 euros tout compris
alors il faut faire des sacrifices je
mets de côté pour beaucoup de familles
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire n'est
pas toujours à la hauteur des dépenses
car si une rentrée en primaire coûte en
moyenne 125 euros
elle atteint 350 euros collège près de
600 euros
au lycée on aimerait qu'ils aient une
modulation de l'allocation rentrée
scolaire selon le niveau de la classe de
manière à ce que la rs correspond au
plus juste des dépenses qui sont
occasionnés par la rentrée pays
trois millions de familles vont toucher
l'allocation de rentrée scolaire elle
est versée automatiquement sauf pour les
enfants uniques comme ils ne sont pas
forcément dont les fichiers de la caisse
d'allocations familiales
c'est à leurs parents de réclamant la
location et pour tout le monde cette
troisième semaine d'août a déjà un petit
parfum de rentrée même en vacances on
profite parfois du temps maussade pour
acheter les articles scolaires dans les
alpes-maritimes les familles étaient
nombreuses aujourd'hui arpenté les
allées des supermarchés à la recherche
de la gomme ou du cahier idéal nathalie
jourdan raymond chape l'art c'est sûr
avec un ciel comme st même brice ne s'y
aventure pas alors une fois le pâté
édifié il ne reste plus que le
supermarché
dès les premières années ça sent déjà la
rentrée
on trouve que rien alors je préfère me
prendre à l'avancé souvenir avant 81 ans
en effet demande déjà des produits
il faut faire plusieurs magasins pour
trouver ces deux ans un aveugle
les fournitures scolaires sont en rayon
depuis une semaine le magasin procèdent
déjà des réassorts pourtant la rentrée
n'est que dans quinze jours on commence
toujours par la maroquinerie scolaire
sur les cartables qui partent en premier
et puis vont le véritablement les plus
épiques c'est une semaine avant la
rentrée et une semaine après au rayon
cartable on ne sait plus où donner du
doigt super-héros exploratrice ou
princesse voilà pour les cartons de la
rentrée son cartable à elle aura des
roulettes
son dos sera épargné par ses tympans ni
ceux de ses petits camarades
tu vas enfin un mozart ça me rappelle
des souvenirs et flûte à bec
souvenirs d'enfance ou de vacances l'été
n'est pas fini mais déjà au rayon
papeterie
il ya comme un petit parfum de nostalgie
soit précédentes on est pourquoi il vaut
mieux pas trop y penser
haut les coeurs il reste encore deux
semaines de répit avant la sonnerie
l'elysée l'a annoncé en fin de journée
la france va envoyer immédiatement deux
cents hommes pour renforcer la finul au
liban paris qui met aussi à la
disposition de la force intérimaire les
1700 soldats déjà présents au large de
beyrouth
ils viendront ainsi soutenir les forces
libanaises qui ont commencé à se
déployer dans le sud du pays
images ici des troupes franchissant le
fleuve litani tout un symbole ce fleuve
était devenue une frontière stratégique
durant le conflit
cela faisait 40 ans que les troupes
libanaises n'avait plus dû lui les pieds
dans le sud du pays
la tante de la population est donc très
forte et la pression sur cette arme est
très grande reportage de nos envoyés
spéciaux
bertrand cocq lionel langlade un petit
air bonhomme pas très martiale mais
c'est l'armée libanaise telle qu'elle a
débarqué aujourd'hui dans le port de tyr
après une traversée de la ville qui n'a
pas soulevé les foules les transports de
troupes sont allés prendre position au
milieu des ruines d'un village chiite
ils sont là pour nous protéger se
réjouissait tea banh aise notre présence
ici est le résultat d'une décision de
l'état dit l'officier et nous sommes là
pour l'exécuter l'état libanais bien sûr
et non pas l'état hezbollah comme on
pourrait le croire
n'oublions pas que le hezbollah aussi a
beaucoup défendu la terre ibanez entre
l'armée et nous on doit ces pôles et se
mélangent et précise même ce jeune
combattant du parti de dieu en vertu de
la résolution votée à new york la
semaine dernière l'armée libanaise doit
prendre la place des troupes
israéliennes qui poursuivent leur
retrait entamé dès après le début de la
trêve
lundi matin les casques bleus de la
finul sont censés faire en sorte que les
deux armées ne se rencontrent jamais
manoeuvres délicates comme le confirme
le général pellegrini moi j'ai bon
espoir que ça prenne pas plus qu'une
quinzaine de jours j'essaie de faire
c'est vrai qu'il faut aller le plus vite
possible trois ans
mais voilà on n'est pas l'abri celle
d'une provocation fondamentaux n'eurent
au début de la semaine prochaine les
premiers renforts onusien devrait
arriver peut-être des éléments du génie
français vous révéler une arme et que
les libanais ont tant de mal à prendre
au sérieux qu il la compare parfois aux
soldats romains d'astérix
s'il est un jour envisager de désarmer
le hezbollah il ne faudra sans doute pas
compter sur cette armée pour s'en
charger en tout cas pas sans aide mais
pour l'instant le gouvernement libanais
se gardent prudemment d'aborder la
question
autre image de cette journée celle des
deux premiers avions commerciaux qui se
sont posés sur l'aéroport de beyrouth
c'est une première depuis un mois malgré
cette autorisation ponctuelle israël
rappelle que le blocus aérien reste pour
l'instant en vigueur en attendant le
déploiement complet des troupes
libanaises dans ce contexte de vie qui
reprend doucement son cours le
gouvernement libanais a été pris de
vitesse par le hezbollah qui a commencé
à prendre en charge les victimes des
bombardements
le chef de la milice chiite a promis un
logement et de l'argent à chaque
sinistré
reportage dans la banlieue chic du
beirut samah soula mathias rond avant la
guerre cet homme avait vu sur le plus
beau quartier de la banlieue sud de
beyrouth
désormais c'est un amas de béton
s'aventure des ombres à la recherche de
leur passé
dans ce chaos le hezbollah a très vite
repris ses droits
barbe fine kalachnikov et au pis ces
hommes quadrillé contrôler chaque
parcelle du quartier schmit équipés de
leurs chasubles
ces deux là sont faits pour être vu et
reconnu
architecte il recense les dégâts pour le
compte du hezbollah et qui spontanément
que la population les interpelle que
nous allons faire tourner deux
ingénieurs par zone on est soixante dix
enfants
on recense le gros des travaux et demain
d'autres ingénieurs du passé dans chaque
maison nous rassure de les voir ses
hommes du parti on sait qu'ils vont tout
reconstruire
reconstruire c'est la promesse d'hassan
nasrallah effacé en un an les
destructions infligées par l'onu mais
par centaines les sans logis de la
guerre s'inscrivent sur les listes
ouvertes par le parti il leur a promis
logement et argent le parti va me donner
un nom de loyer de quoi m'acheter des
meubles de qualité
voyez comme ils sont attentionnés cette
femme habite un quartier chrétien mais
son cabinet médical qui a été détruit
était dans cette banlieue chante
où on a on a confiance a fait cela parce
que tant qu'il promesses
pour m quelque chose ils le font le
responsable de cette cellule hesbollah
nous parle d'un délai de 48 heures pour
les versements aucune inquiétude face
aux coûts d'une telle promesse on a de
la voix du jeune blanc à draria je vous
demande de l'argent et une méticuleuse
organisation digne d'un régime
soviétique
pas question pour le hezbollah de voir
un mécontentement populaire entaché sa
prétendue victoire après sa
démonstration par les armes le hezbollah
s'installe sur le terrain social et
politique pour le parti de dieu
il s'agit à présent de gagner la paix il
ne faut pas oublier que c'est
l'enlèvement de deux soldats israéliens
qui a été l'un des facteurs déclencheurs
du conflit la résolution 1701 de l'onu
demande bien sûr leur libération
mais pour l'instant les familles sont
sans nouvelles depuis plus d'un mois
rencontre avec l'une d'entre elles qui
maintient la mobilisation mais reste
confiante gérard êtes bêtes mosti à mal
pendant toute l'interview elle touche
son alliance et très vite elle nous
montre les photos de son mariage c'était
en octobre dernier le voyage de noces à
istanbul des vacances au népal charny tu
as appris par l'armée que son mari avait
disparu au nord d'israël enlevés ou tués
par le hezbollah l'armée m'a dit il y à
sept morts et de kidnapper un des morts
n'a pas encore été identifié et on ne
sait pas si c'est ton marque grâce à une
analyse adn carnutes apprend que son
mari n'est pas mort qu'il a été enlevé
ici en territoire israélien c'était le
12 juillet le lendemain
l'armée entre en guerre contre le
hezbollah pour récupérer ses deux
soldats aujourd'hui avec le cessez le
feu
on peut négocier je ne pense pas que
cela puisse se passer directement mais
les conditions sont maintenant réunies
pour une libération
vous ne pensez pas que ça aurait pu se
faire sans cette guerre veut pas
répondre à cette question
toute la famille du soldat ou 10 est
mobilisé pour répondre en permanence aux
journalistes cela fait plus d'un mois
sans aucune nouvelle nous n'arrêterons
pas tant que je ne verrai pas mon fils
ouvrir cette porte est entré dans notre
maison
après 34 jours de guerre israël n'a pas
récupéré ces deux soldats enlevaient
mais ici personne ne les a oubliés la
presse en parle tous les jours et l'on
espère maintenant que des négociations
secrètes permettront leur libération
depuis les attentats du 11 septembre les
américains n'ont cessé de demander aux
autorités l'accès à tous les
enregistrements sonores des personnes
enfermées dans les tours
de nouveaux témoignages viennent d'être
rendues publiques écouter celui de cette
jeune femme bloquée au 83e étage martin
laroche joubert
pascal geoffrion mélissa a disparu un
message de détresse
parmi plus de les écouter par les
familles des victimes elles ont vite
posé plainte pour pouvoir écouter ces
nouveaux témoignages
il reflète la détresse mais aussi la
confusion dans l'organisation des
ça fait mal au coeur de savoir que dans
une situation comme celle ci il n'y
avait pas les équipements tout fallait
pour communiquer c'est la quatrième fois
après les témoignages sont rendus
publics mais les voies de la plupart des
victimes ont été entendues par les
familles seulement en raison de la
charge émotionnelle entendant ces gens
qui étaient tellement calme ça va plus
loin que l'héroïsme c'est autre chose
al'approche du cinquième anniversaire
des événements du 11 septembre
l'enregistrement empreinte d'une
résonance particulière ce sont
probablement les derniers qui sont
rendus publics afin de préserver
l'intimité des familles des victimes aux
états unis où l'on suit avec beaucoup
d'attention une saga judiciaire qui a
peut-être trouvé son épilogue un
américain vient d'être arrêté en
thaïlande il avoué le meurtre il ya dix
ans d'une fillette lauréate des concours
de beauté
à l'époque l'affairé avait suscité
beaucoup d'émotion les parents avaient
même été soupçonné claude sens par son
visage avait ému tous les américains
elle avait 6 ans s'appelait john bennet
ramsay elle avait gagné plusieurs
concours de mini-miss aux états unis
le 26 décembre 1996 au lendemain de noël
elle est retrouvée morte battu et
étranglé dans le sous sol de sa maison
un assassinat qui soulèvent une émotion
considérable aux états unis les obsèques
à peine terminée les parents sont
soupçonnés pendant des années assailli
par la presse
ils ont dû se défendre avec acharnement
comment peut-on imaginer que j'ai tué ma
petite fille mon petit trésor ils n'ont
toutes les preuves qu'on n'a pas tué la
police doit chercher ailleurs dix ans
prône la mort de la petite john bennet
ramsay l'histoire vient de rebondir en
thaïlande devant la presse convoqué pour
l'occasion la police a présenté hier cet
homme à la chemise bleue un américain de
41 ans instituteur qui vivait à bangkok
et qui vient d'avouer le meurtre de la
petite fille
j'étais avec john bennet ramsay quand
elle est morte il y avait quelqu'un
d'autre non l'homme reste silencieux
quelques secondes plus tard il dit
simplement sa mort était un accident
disons enquête pour enfin connaître une
part de la vérité
le père de john bennet rams 1 fait part
de son soulagement la nouvelle de cette
arrestation
la mère qui avait été traîné dans la
boue pendant des années qui s'étaient
battus jusqu'au bout et décédé en juin
dernier d'un cancer 1 n'aura jamais
connu la vérité sur la mort de sa fille
en un an le prix du pétrole a flambé de
20 % la facture s'alourdit pour les
consommateurs et la manne grossi pour
les pays producteurs
on estime que les recettes du pétrole
s'élève en 2006 à 1000 milliards de
dollars dans les pays du golfe l'argent
continue donc à couler à flots david
bowie christophe vignal des gratte ciel
qui pousse en plein désert des îles
artificielles construites de toutes
pièces en pleine mer autant de projets
faramineux financé par l'afflux de
pétrodollars en 2006 avec la flambée du
prix du baril les pays du golfe
toucheront le jackpot
l'arabie saoudite devrait gagner près de
190 millions
art de dollars de quoi acheter en une
seule fois à la bourse de paris edf
renault france télécom le groupe peugeot
et danone sur le podium
l'arabie saoudite occupe la première
place suivie par la russie avec des
recettes estimées à 150 milliards de
dollars et en troisième position un pays
européen
la norvège au moyen-orient après
l'argent facile dans les années 70 les
monarchies pétrolières réaliste
aujourd'hui que l'or noir n'est pas
éternel l'heure est désormais aux
économies la plupart de ces pays se sont
dotés de fonds de fonds de réserve qui
sont souvent appelés des fonds de
réserve pour les générations futures
et sur ces fonds ouverts ce
automatiquement un certain pourcentage
des recettes pétrolières qui ne seront
utilisées qu'après mais la source à
dollar est encore loin d'être tarie
cette année le pétrole n'aura jamais
autant rapporté dans le monde
mille milliards de dollars de revenus
c'est par exemple l'équivalent de la
dette de la france une flambée qui amène
les consommateurs à trouver des
solutions alternatives aux états unis
certains automobilistes remplace le
carburant par de l'huile de friteuse
il paraît que ça marche et en plus c'est
écologique et économique martine
laroche-joubert douglas higginbotham le
prix de l'essence oblige près de la
moitié des américains faire des
économies une contrainte dont johnattan
prat monsieur giguère restaurateurs ils
recyclent lui même ses huiles de cuisson
car la vieille voiture consommer
beaucoup d'essence à peu près 24 litres
aux 100 km ma femme m'a dit que c'était
trop elle en a parlé à mon associé qui
m'a refilé un bouquin qui s'appelle de
la fuite aux au réservoir
on ouvre cette valve on recueille louis
l'ont la filtre pour la nettoyer
alors on la met dans ce bidonville à 10
et on la porte à la voiture direction le
garage ou de johnatan a débarqué il ya
deux ans j'ai acheté un kit jeu les
affecter aux mécaniciens a joué l'hymne
mets ça sur la voiture il m'a regardé
comme si j'étais un idiot et john salut
je sais que c'est toi chante on odeurs
de frites
le kit empêche ce drôle de carburant
d'épaissir il s'adapte sont des
véhicules diesel et ça marche
on assiste à une demande très fort à
chaque fois que le prix de l'essence
augmente pour les amateurs nouveau
termineront au camp tous les avantages
c'est une énorme économie c'est mieux
pour l'environnement qui nous dépendons
moins de l'étranger le plat permet de
faire plus d'une centaine de kilomètres
traditionnellement les restaurateurs
pèse pour se débarrasser ces tuiles
c'est bon pour l'écologie car c'est un
déchet c'est peut-être pas grand-chose
mais à notre manière nous réduisons
notre dépendance vis-à-vis du pétrole
étranger
chacun agit comme il le peut alors
l'huile de friture deviendra-t-elle
l'essence du futur c'est en tout cas une
piste explorée en france une personne
est morte et une autre a été blessée
dans l'accident d'un avion de tourisme
l'appareil s'est écrasé hier soir à
l'atterrissage sur la commune d'arbois
dans le jura depuis début janvier une
trentaine de personnes sont déjà
décédées dans ce type d'accident
c'est autant que pour toute l'année
donné 5 les autorités rappellent donc
les mesures de sécurité et de prudence
les conditions météo ne doivent pas être
sous-estimés christophe rosie david
fossard sécurité aux abords vérifie à
droite devant et la gauche qui est
personne pas d'avion
dans l'aviation légère certaines
consignes de sécurité peuvent paraître
évidentes et pendant un cours de
pilotage
on ne laisse rien au hasard la sécurité
est omniprésente
pas étonnant quand on sait que dans 75 %
des accidents
il n'y a qu'une seule cause l'erreur
humaine un problème de connaissance de
réglementation est aussi un problème
d'entraînement mais l'entraînement on ne
fait pas tout le 31 juillet dernier un
pilote expérimenté sa femme et sa
belle-mère devait rejoindre la rochelle
depuis la normandie
ils ont trouvé la mort dans ce champ de
loire-atlantique mauvaise appréciation
des conditions météo
la météo justement premier réflexe de
l'apprenti pilote bien avant de décoller
toujours un petit coup d'oeil vers le
ciel la prise d'informations météo avant
tout vol 1 permet de s'assurer que le
vol peut être fait dans une bonne
condition de sécurité en respectant la
réglementation procédure oblige on passe
ensuite par une courte préparation
théorique toujours ton ange dangereux
d'accord puis l'avion est passé au
crible
histoire d'éviter les mauvaises
surprises en vol alors on vérifie que
les commandes de vol sont bien libre et
que les ailes sont dont nous entendons
de magie il faut obtenu la licence de
pilotage est valable deux ans pour
prolonger ce délai il faut avoir volé au
moins douze heures lors de la dernière
année mais les professionnels le savent
il ne faut surtout pas se remettre aux
commandes après une longue période sans
piloter ne jamais hésiter donc à
reprendre des cours une petite révision
pour éviter la catastrophe
l'été c'est une période de grosse
activité pour les petits cirques qui
profite d'un public plus disponibles des
troupes qui ont souvent du mal à trouver
des lieux d'accueil
la concurrence est rude et parfois les
chapiteaux s'installe en toute
illégalité
jacques devaux jean francois monier
le cirque thierry zavatta est de retour
à saint-cast-le-guildo une installation
tout à fait légal ce qui n'avait pas été
le cas la fois précédente
le 13 juillet dernier le cirque avait
dressé son chapiteau sans aucune
autorisation
un passage en force justifiée selon son
directeur par le refus de nombreuses
municipalités d'accueillir un cirque
si j'avais côté les mairies en fait avec
une seule réponse je refais qu'un seul
spectacle en juillet serait très
difficile vous croyez pas eh ben je me
suis installé sans autorisation
c'est un peu la foire d'empoigné l'été
dans les stations balnéaires petits et
grands cirques tente de se faire une
place au soleil car le potentiel est
fort tous les coups sont permis y
compris de s'installer avant le passage
prévu d'un confrère et simplement dire
assez pâtissière fait attention quand
vous les perdez une place parce que vous
estimez que le maire n'a pas été réglo
avec vous vous la prenez mais vous
éviter de passer devant un confrère
c'est inélégant voilà c'est tout mais
bon on peut le comprendre par le
désespoir de certains et les communes
dans tout cela
accusé de ne pas laisser suffisamment de
place au cirque
elle rétorque ils ne sont pas les seuls
à vouloir s'installer sur des lieux
publics dans la mesure où la
programmation est prévu ça ne pose pas
de problème ce qui pose problème c'est
le cirque qui arrivent à l'improviste et
qui vient s'installer sur un espace qui
est déjà occupée par une autre
manifestation
il est là le problème c'est que l'on ne
peut pas avoir sur un même espace de
cirque ou deux manifestations parce que
l'espace n'est pas extensible à l'infini
il y à 2 146 traditionnelle en france
difficile de satisfaire tout le monde
d'autant que les aménagements urbains
permettent de moins en moins d'installer
des chapiteaux au coeur des villes le
pari fou d'un passionné de vieilles
pierres il y a dix ans il s'est lancé le
défi de construire un château fort en
bourgogne uniquement avec des outils
médiévaux aujourd'hui 45 personnes
travaillent sur le chantier où les
visiteurs se pressent pour découvrir
l'oeuvre de ses bâtisseurs un peu décalé
dans le temps
anne-sophie chamiers lecomte clos il
compte
c'est un chantier hors du temps perdu
aux confins du côté d'auxerre nevers
nous sommes en 12 137 une bande de fous
construite un château fort pour eux le
21e siècle appartient un millénaire
inconnu à guédelon les outils et les
méthodes de travail respecte la
tradition du moyen-age on préfère
provins faire de mauvaise qualité que
les outils suis beaucoup plus vite et
qu'on soit comme en troisième siècle
dans la forge le feu ne doit jamais
s'éteindre
ted le maître faivre fonds et frappe
tous les outils du chantier ébauchoir
ciseaux chaque artisan vient de
commander des pièces comme clément le
tailleur de pierre sous les yeux des
visiteurs
il va travailler le bloc de grès pendant
trois jours premier boulot faire de la
géométrie
une fois qu'on a fait là je mettrai sur
la pirogue on va découper celui qui a eu
cette idée folle un jour d'inventer riez
de long c'est michel guyot passionnés de
vieilles pierres mais frustrés de ne pas
satisfaire sa curiosité savez quand on
rentre dans une case une église romane
ou dans un château
mais comment est ce qu'ils ont fait pour
arriver à monter cette croisée d'ogives
pour monter cet arc en place sainte où
est ce qu'il recherchait la fondation la
meilleure réponse c'est de se lancer
dans la construction
dix ans de chantier et déjà 50 salariés
pour ce logis seigneurial 250 mille
visiteurs par an guédelon est le site le
plus visité de bourgogne juste derrière
les hospices de beaune
un rêve de gosse sur papier qui
deviendra un jour réalité mais en
attendant une nouvelle journée sachet
sur le chantier la porte du château
devrait s'ouvrir en 2025
pendant soixante ans il avait gardé le
secret l'écrivain allemand günter grass
prix nobel de littérature en 99 vient
d'avouer qu'il avait été enrôlé chez les
waffen ss la terrible unité d'élite
nazis révélations faites à l'occasion de
la sortie de son autobiographie
c'est un choc chez les intellectuels
allemands car l'homme est une figure
morale du pays christophe airaud
confessions tardives sur un plateau de
télévision pour günther grass l'écrivain
allemand révèle son engagement à l'âge
de 17 ans dans la waffen ss
jusqu'à ce jour il avait prétendu avoir
appartenu uniquement à la défense anti
aérienne
mais durant trois mois février mars
avril 1945 il s'enrôle dans la terrible
unité d'élite du régime nazi
une tâche refoulés depuis soixante ans
que l'écrivain ne dévoile aujourd'hui je
n'ai pas fait avant je dois le dire
sûrement je devrai attendre encore
longtemps tous ces reproches ma vie
jusqu'à maintenant été marquées par 7 e
cet aveu trouble l'image morale que
dégage le prix nobel de littérature en
effet depuis 60 ans il dénonce écrit et
réfléchie les silences des allemands
durant le régime nazi
le tambour est créée en 1959 puis porté
à l'écran en est la preuve
ce récit d'une enfance terrifié par le
régime nazi ce goûteur gras s'érige
comme le porte parole d'une génération
bafoués
les reproches ce silence pendant 60 ans
surtout quand vous vous prétendez
moraliste comme l'a fait gunter grass
durant toutes ces années
cette confession est issu de son
autobiographie vendus en quelques jours
à plus de cent mille exemplaires acte
courageux à l'issue d'une vie
d'intellectuels ou mensonge trop
tardivement dévoilé l'allemagne est
l'écrivain se retrouve une fois encore
face à leur passé et leur mémoire
on a appris cet après midi le décès
d'une des grandes figures du service
public bernard rapp c'était un à l'âge
de 61 ans grand reporter puis
présentateurs des journaux animateurs de
la conviviale assiette anglaise
c'était aussi un homme de lettres qui
avait orienté avec brio sa carrière vers
le cinéma à bernard lebrun bien rude
journée qu'avec aujourd'hui rien guindée
ce fameux flegme britannique toute la
carrière lui collera à la peau de notre
correspondant à londres hôte en 2006
thatcher mister what gagnera ses galons
de présentateur du 20h en 1983 au temps
d'antenne 2 est déjà de la guerre au
liban
le projet de loi de 1983 à 1987
autant de des groupes drucker aux
contamines bernard rapp présente à
chaque jour le journal
osant même le premier retirer la
sacro-sainte crav mais ironie de
l'histoire ce n'est qu'après après avoir
quitté son siège qu'il sera consacré
meilleur présentateur levier c'est banal
c'est vrai une équipe derrière le
journal mais sans journal n'y a pas de
présentateur
mais il n'avait pas fini d'inventer pour
la télévision avec humour et énergie
bernard rapp chef de bande sera l'homme
de l'assiette anglaise et autres
tranches de cake à présent journaliste
écrivain animateur et réalisateur jamais
sans mon livre un siècle d'écrivains un
football qu'un son premier film en 1996
tiré à part était tombée d'une étagère
forcément anglaise
son thème la manipulation mais comme il
le disait avec humour ce n'est pas du
tout du tout la manipulation qui
l'éloigna de la télévision
c'est la télévision c'est l'avis de
faire de la fiction c'est de faire du
cinéma
heinrich boll pris toute sa vie bernard
rêvait de diriger un orchestre comme il
dirigeait ses équipes à l'unisson et
dans le respect du talent de chacun un
défi 61 ans bernard rapp est parti après
une longue maladie
la rédaction de france 2 ce soir lui dit
merci et partage de chagrin des 6 1
saluant l'homme le confrère l'aîné
l'homme de lettres l'homme de londres
voilà c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
vous d'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo patrice drevet suivi du point
route avec julien pascal 20h50 et bly a
une portée disparue je vous retrouve à
22h55 pour une immersion totale au
tribunal de troyes demain vous retrouvez
françoise laborde je vous dis à très
bientôt excellente soirée sur france 2